I think aljose historically speaking I
think he's owed a rematch generally if
you get caught you do a rematch anytime
you're hit with one punch and you go
down that goes into the criteria's cop
plus I think he had set a record with
defenses even though it was only a
couple but bantamweight it's it's such a
a musical chairs over there
aljo did make one mistake though which
is he didn't ask for the rematch he did
not in the ring ask for it so Sean moved
on to Cheeto cheetah was there the press
conference is in the back he got all
three players there it seemed like maybe
he did things in the in the wrong order
but I don't think that that aljo going
to social media is going to be able to
build a fire as much as the one that he
smoldered live in the ring and I don't
think he's next I don't think I don't
think morale playing the game of I'm not
going to fight aljo I don't think
Henry's in the discussion even as great
as he is yes I think it's Cheeto me too
I agree I think it's June December